on a clear night the sky is full of
stars and constellations that humans
have gazed upon across the ages
but now some of these bright lights are
impostors
they're communication satellites moving
quickly through low earth orbit and
they're the first wave and massive
fleets that will deliver internet to
remote corners of the globe even as they
rewrite the familiar patterns in the
night sky
the leader so far is starlink a project
of the rocket company spacex which has
launched more than 1700 with tens of
thousands more on the way
other companies are hot on starlink's
trail and have begun building their own
large swarms
some versions of these plants call for
more than 100 000 of these satellites in
orbit by the end of the decade bright
dots creeping across our celestial
sphere
the companies promise to democratize
internet access for remote rural and
underserved communities but their
satellite constellations also pose grave
challenges to ground-based astronomy
in the early hours of night before these
low orbiting satellites disappeared
fully into earth's shadow
the initial starling satellites were
among the brightest points of light in
the sky
so bright that they threatened to
disrupt the gaze of sensitive optical
telescopes
as their light trails cross the
firmament also at risk are some of the
very communities that mega constellation
companies aim to help
indigenous groups with traditions built
around astronomy
with thousands of satellites in orbit
the night sky would fundamentally change
altering the stories that people have
written in the stars
starlink engineers have worked with
astronomers to find ways to dim their
satellites including by adding sun
visors to block reflections but it's
unclear if other companies will follow
suit and there are few regulations to
restrict commercial efforts in space
some legal scholars believe that space
is becoming a new arena for
environmental conflict and that
environmental protection laws could one
day be applied to low earth orbit
but those regulatory changes will be
years in the making
as space itself opens for business the
fates of precious science and storied
cultures hang in the balance
you